The balance keeps the balance in balance, bumps the value into numbers, and
adds a temporary restriction on power.The
rate at which you can receive the benefits of status points is
1 point for every 100,000 mani.My total total is 300
points.Take 50 points each as a pioneer.
[Music]  ] I want to
recover my lost stamina and my status has
increased.I was wondering if it was Pencilgon's doing or what he was messing with with Wind, but it turned out to be stamina that had increased.Luckily, I knew that no matter
where you attacked, you wouldn't get any damage.
[Music] It's
not the first time I've fought someone like that. It's a
fighting skill whose attack power is calculated not by strength but by luck.
[Music] A
swordsman without a sword is the same as a sword without a sword.  Zaha,
hey white bastard Umehoshi, I'm starting over again with my
skills. I've buried my head, let's
move it.
[Music]
Omo